so what i'm trying to do is show people
here's the leverage we have and by the
way
employers have huge leverage that they
have not even started using so
i have eight chapters in the book that
are focused on what individuals can do
looking at different scenarios where you
need some people need advice
and then i have three chapters for
employers and i think employers are
really the sleeping giant in all this
healthcare reform healthcare reform
battle
employers have been passively passing
this cost on to their employees that's
what's been happening over the past
decades
it's now become so um unbearable
and shameful that that everybody knows
it
because everyday working americans just
can't even afford these deductibles and
high
premiums that they're being forced to
pay so
i think that if employers and employees
could get on the same page and realize
how much of their money is being
unjustly burned and wasted and
squandered by our health care system
we have what they need to survive they
need
our money if they don't have our money
they've got nothing
and so what we need to do is identify
there's price variation for every
product in every market
find the people who are giving you the
low price the fair price
and reward them with your business and
if somebody is charging you a high price
don't give them your business it's
really as simple as that and once
once we start you know you're seeing
that now where more
employers who are self-funded are
entering into direct contracts
with primary care doctors or even with
specialists you see like walmart has
their centers of excellence plan
where if you need a knee replacement say
they say well you can go anywhere you
want but if you go to this center
in your region that we have a direct pay
relationship with
we'll waive all your copays all your
deductibles all your cost sharing
and you'll get that paid for 100 by the
employer sponsored health benefits plan
nothing out of your pocket
the quality is actually going to be
better
and the care is going to be a lot
cheaper and so you see more
progressively minded employers
creating these different models and i
think that really is the future of where
we're going and where we need to go
there can be debates i feel like
medicare for all
is like a political football that people
like to kick back and forth
use as a talking point to rile up their
base
but the difficulty of putting something
in place like that
i mean the obstacles that would have to
be overcome are absolutely
enormous whereas what we can do right
now
is employers and employees can get on
the same page they can see how they
they've been exploited and they can
start
going to the people who treat them
fairly and
shunning the ones that don't and
sometimes the ones that don't treat
us fairly are the big brand name marquee
insurance companies and medical
facilities
those frankly are some of the worst
offenders and we need to
shun them yeah andrew and i've talked a
lot we don't i don't love the concept of
your healthcare being tied to your
employment i think that
um in the 21st century economy it stop
it makes less and less sense over and
over the more you the more you unpack
you peel back that onion
but it is a competitive differentiator
for employees
or for employers to say hey you come
work here
like your healthcare is covered uh we
got your back um
and like and good companies do that um
yeah that's even but let me let me just
point out something here i mean i'm
trying to reframe the way we think about
this stuff
because there's even a myth of this idea
of rich health benefits right
because all of that money that the
employer
is paying in health benefits belongs to
the employee
in the form of the employee compensation
uh when you're paying too much and it
should be going to the person
yeah that's just taking more money out
of your wages
so these rich health benefits that all
the white white-collar workers get
touched they're they're they're being
fooled
this is how the system wants you to
think about it oh your employer's paying
no you're the one paying for this you're
right the employer is funding
the compensation and then we're
compensated through our wages
our health benefits our paid time off
our maybe a
hopefully a retirement plan contribution
so that's our benefits package
that is our pool of compensation but
100 of the money once the employer funds
our health benefits
that all belongs to the employee and i
compare this to like your employer
taking you out
saying hey i want to take you out to a
fancy restaurant let's go out for dinner
so you go to this five-star place your
employer says order whatever you want
it's on it's on me you're like great so
you know you're getting the steak you're
getting the flambe dessert you know
wine well they they bring the check and
they put it on the table
and your employer reaches into your
wallet and pulls out your credit card
and pays
the bill that's what it's like when you
have rich health benefits
that are supposedly paid for by your
employer it's not paid for by your
employer folks it's coming out of your
compensation
and so then there's less money available
to pay you wages
and if you look at the studies that have
been done it shows
wage wages are stagnant in the united
states over the last two decades in
large part
because health care costs are consuming
employee compensation
at an unreasonable rate fascinating and
that's right because i pay
depending on the company we've run it's
500 to 1000 bucks a month
per employee and you can get scale on
that you can
dial up dial down the benefits um but
and in most cases what i just talked
about let's say i land at 750
an employee right in the middle there
the employee still has to pay for crap
like it doesn't even fully so now i only
have taken 750 bucks a month from you
the employee but also you're still stuck
with um
whatever the difference is in your
actual medical bills it's a mess your
book talks about this your website
eventually have
advice for people to start to navigate
this
i love the advice on how to go to small
claims court because that sounds
daunting and like a pain in the butt
and it's probably not i mean it's time
consuming
right but it's if done well i mean a lot
of judges um when it's the
the small human versus the big company
they're inclined in that type of court
to side with the human
um especially if there's someone who
probably takes the time to read your
book
and knows their stuff if you will um
another thing you say in your book is
um talk about making friends with your
debt collector
um how does that work because that's
like
i don't know maybe it's like the you
know you're you're in ministry like i
think in back
in like biblical terms it's like we
don't like the debt collectors or
whatever it was i mean maybe jesus did
but
that's right the tax collectors are the
worst right yeah the
the i would say the debt collector is
the modern day tax collector
um scorned you know the the uh
the parasite on yeah right yeah yeah so
so so i think the thing is is that i
talked for this chapter so in each
chapter i tried to feature
an expert who could be like a guide into
this world
to help us to show us how to win right i
don't know personally i've
i thankfully have not had medical debt
thankfully
and so i haven't had to encounter this
myself but i talked to jerry ashton
who founded the charity rip medical debt
and
what he used to be a debt collector for
decades in health care
and so jerry knows the ins and the outs
of the industry and that led him to
start this charity that actually
buys people's medical debt and forgives
it so i asked jerry what's the right
approach here how do you handle this
and he explained again medical debt like
your medical bills you
don't want to avoid it when the medical
debt collector calls you
in fact the first thing you want to do
is dispute the debt in writing
immediately even if you think oh i did
go to that doctor i went to that
hospital
dispute it in writing make them prove
that they're the ones that own the debt
that they're the ones that are justified
to collect for it also i would assume
that any medical debt that's out there
is based on erroneous bills and jacked
up
unfair prices because that's the
standard in the industry
so i would not assume personally that
any medical debt
is as a result of just somebody
not paying an honest bill um i and so
it's also i think one of the
just great shames of our country that we
have this problem but the the point is
you have to negotiate
with that medical debt collector to get
out from under the debt let's say it's a
legitimate debt
you're going to dispute it but let's say
you're going to come to a you need to
come to an agreement i like to use the
term
we need to come to an agreement that
works well for both of us so when you're
talking to that medical debt collector
you need to understand
how much money can that debt collector
get from you
and still be seen as a winner in his
boxes eyes
i did right i won hey boss i won for you
i collected
and the surprising thing is what jerry
told me is
if your debt gets sold to a debt buyer
it was probably sold for pennies on the
dollar he said maybe a nickel on the
dollar
at the most so therefore if you owe
a thousand dollars the hospital says you
owe a thousand
it would have been sold to a debt
collector for
f what's what's 5 percent 50 bucks
in other words if you pay more than 50
to that debt
buyer they're profiting so i asked jerry
what's
what do you think is the range the ratio
of discount that you think would
make the met the debt buyer and debt
collector feel like they got a win
he said probably 15 percent so let's say
you're going to try and get that
thousand dollars you owe down to 15
this all comes now down to negotiation
right i'm sure you've done a lot of
negotiating i've done some negotiating
in my time
i love that process but it doesn't help
to have it be hostile and
confrontational
so you're going to want to cuss that
debt collector out you're going to want
to tell them how unfair it is
that they're coming after you what a
scumbag they are to be
in the business they're doing i mean
you're going to maybe want to say all
those things
but what if you said hey look i would
really love to pay you this
the problem is i don't have the money
and unless you can give me
a massive discount i am
not going to be able to pay anything to
you and you're just going to take an l
on this one
so what tell me let's let's talk let me
tell you about my family i got bills
you know have them get to know you get
to know them as a human being
and then if you do come to an agreement
jerry's other big
piece of advice is do not ever enter
an agreement with a medical debt
collector that you won't be able to
stay true to because if you violate that
agreement even once you miss one payment
on a payment plan
they will come after you then for the
entire amount
it's the whole thing so just hold them
off your credit's already
hurt because of the medical debt hold
them off make them think they're not
going to get anything
unless they get a great deal from you be
the friendliest person they've ever met
so that you know they actually want to
give you a good deal it's amazing how
much
you know more bees with honey whenever
more bees with honey right
[Music]
you